so let me ask about one question about
Trump he certainly gets all the press
we're not going to give him that much
but I hear a lot of people say you know
that's just a bubble you know it's going
to go away just the way Herman Cain and
Michele Bachmann and all these people
did but you know you kids are a little
young to remember but that's what they
said about Ronald Reagan I remember when
he was 12 years old in 1968 when he
first floated the bubble of running and
it was a joke oh come on he had a stupid
television show he's divorced he avoided
combat
he's got weird hair and crazy face paint
this guy will never so for all those
people who say Donald Trump could not go
all the way I don't think they're right
they didn't say he would get this far
and obviously I don't know what the
results are from last night but Fox
tried to put a stake in him and I don't
think they did I agree with you
completely crazy to dismiss his chances
to be the Republican nominee when you
have 17 candidates in the race he's
polling at 25 percent right now he may
collapse but he may not and you can
certainly be the Republican nominee
getting 25 26 27 percent of the vote and
his message is powerful which is our
leaders in Washington are incompetent
the country is falling apart I'm going
to fix it and make America great again
he's not talking about policies a lot of
what he says is nonsense talk but if he
is saying he is saying Sandeep Lydia
doesn't listen listen he is saying I
yes no policies he is saying out loud
what millions of people across this
country are screaming at their
television sets every night and the
notion he can't win I think is dead what
like like take for example what he said
about Obamacare I will repeal it and
replace it with something terrific yeah
is that that is the best way to
summarize terrific way to describe his
rhetoric and policy it has the form and
substance of fog there is simply no
there there there's no nothing real
about what do the people care I I think
this I think this is wearing thin I
thought last night was the beginning of
the process of decoupling ourselves from
him and I think once the media starts
focusing on the other candidates that's
when it begins to shrink and I just see
that isn't inevitable respecting your
example of Reagan this is no Reagan and
I'm not here celebrating Reagan but
there were a little more principles
attached to Reagan's approach to
governing yeah he was a little better
than something terrific here's what he
has and I admitted to have a better
chance at going all the way if you had
hair like yours possibly but he is its
dream on lady message I'm saying there's
we not was the last time you saw James
Carville's hair I like
it's been a long time listen here's what
he has it speaks to steve's point he and
which is been driving conservatives
crazy right-wing nuts like me for two
cycles now he has confidence and he's
not defensive and he doesn't accept the
premise of the question and
conservatives want somebody who's going
to stand up for what we believe in and
he if he's at least standing up for the
principles and why it was on what
principle he's not just a star that
there there's a core competence of
government that is missing and i know
that government can work i'm not
anti-gun republican anti-gay we've made
new orleans work you made San Francisco
work federalism works the federal
government is not working but but to his
point earlier um it just seemed like
they don't have any specifics or they do
not want to deal with reality it seems
like we different in the Republicans it
looks like the Democrats at least deal
with reality whereas the and look in the
mirror sometimes and ask you to as a
country whereas everything with the
Republicans is it's the fault of China
Mexico and Iran and of course lazy
takers who use their welfare money to
buy drugs well I think you saw I think
you saw any one of a number of
Republican candidates last night with an
aspirational message Marco Rubio is one
of them talked about the future talked
about the sharing economy talked about
the displacement of middle income
workers that Amazon largest retailer in
the world doesn't own a single store now
Donald Trump talking about I'm gonna
build a great wall with a great door in
the middle of course it's all nonsense
talk and Rick Perry Rick Perry to his
great credit gave a great speech where
he talked about the trumpism as a cancer
on conservative rhythm and he's exactly
right what does it tell you about your
party that the guy who is leaving you
keep saying is full of nonsense
yeah well
you're saying I'm not says about the
party and what it says about Washington
is people in this country have
completely totally lost trust with their
leaders in Washington Republicans have
seen Republican leaders in Washington
spend the country 218 trillion dollars
in debt abdicate their principles year
after year after year and they're angry
as hell about it and they are responding
to the angriest Massimo
you